yeah I mean like that mine was really
that the only kind of superhero who I
really had any kind of connection with
when I was going out I don't know it's
very very very daunting Robert Pattinson
to the cave by now you've probably heard
Rob as the new Batman but he's opening
up about the casting for the first time
in the new issue of variety our paths
will hit the big screen as Bruce Wayne
in 2021 and director Matt Reeves the
Batman
I really like Matt Reeves and has set up
for I mean it's an interesting direction
I don't think it's it's something for my
comics which hasn't been really explored
its kind of crazy shoes to thought I
mean it's interesting what the different
directions you can take with it I mean
you can do quite a lot with it in main
news of his casting was leaked to the
press
and let's just say Robert was not too
happy about it
quote when knapping leaked I was king
furious everyone was so upset everyone
was panicking from my team in fact he
was even worried he might lose the role
because of it it was terrifying I was
like oh [ __ ] does that screw me because
they are so intent on secrecy of course
all's well that ends well and the part
of the Dark Knight still belonged to
Robert and get ready for some seriously
sweet irony guys my last day with Chris
Nilan
yeah you heard that right Robert
actually got the career-changing news on
his first day on the set of Christopher
Nolan's film Tennant is the best and Ike
it's kind of I mean it's definitely
unlike anything I've ever worked Chris
actually wrote and directed the Dark
Knight trilogy now if that isn't so
Hollywood I don't know what is Robert
reportedly got the roll over Nicholas
Hoult and opened up about how he plans
to portray Batman quote you're trying to
think of the way to balance how do I
bring something new to it and not want
to scare people off and work in the
confines of the costume full-body
coverage people sounds claustrophobic to
me
but Robert dished on putting on the
legendary suit for the first time quote
it's maybe the craziest thing I've ever
done you do feel very powerful
immediately but getting in that thing
not so easy
quote the ritual of getting into it is
pretty humiliating you've got five
people trying to shove you into
something once you've got it on it's
like yeah I feel strong I feel tough
even though I had to have someone
squeezing my butt cheeks into the legs
now there's a visual you're welcome of
course
et will bring you all the latest news on
Robert Pattinson and his role in the
Batman so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stevens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]